Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，比如咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改拿铁订单还来得及吗？但有了 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，
you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
你就不会有这些顾虑了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家，由于艾格林顿跨城轻轨（Eglinton Crosstown LRT）正在进行列车测试，请务必小心。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能经过轨道。请记住遵守所有交通信号。在我们的轨道沿线要小心，且仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. Almost a century and a half ago, one of Sir Ed Davies' predecessors, a chap called William Gladstone, invented modern political campaigning. Before the general election of 1880, Gladstone gave a series of set-piece speeches, many of them five hours long, which audiences flocked to in their tens of thousands. He spoke righteous moral indignation about the various abominations of the incumbent government, led by his great rival, Benjamin Disraeli. Eyewitness accounts speak of audience members becoming so enraptured that they fainted and had to be carried out over the heads of the gathered masses like plague corpses. A few weeks later, through little more than the soaring power of his oratory, Gladstone returned once again to 10 Downing Street and ended Disraeli's career. 144 years later, it's hard to tell if the hand of history weighs heavy on Ed
保持警惕，注意周围，确保安全。大约一个半世纪前，埃德·戴维爵士（Sir Ed Davies）的前任之一，一位名叫威廉·格莱斯顿（William Gladstone）的家伙，发明了现代政治竞选活动。在 1880 年大选之前，格莱斯顿发表了一系列精心准备的演讲，其中许多长达五个小时，成千上万的听众蜂拥而至。他以正义的道德义愤，抨击了由他伟大的竞争对手本杰明·迪斯雷利（Benjamin Disraeli）领导的现任政府的种种罪恶。据目击者称，听众们听得如痴如醉，以至于有人当场昏厥，不得不像瘟疫死尸一样被从人群头顶抬出去。几周后，凭借他那高超的演说力量，格莱斯顿再次入主唐宁街 10 号，终结了迪斯雷利的政治生涯。144 年后，很难说历史的重担是否压在埃德
Davies' shoulders. One of the many reasons that it's hard to tell is because you only get to glimpse his face for precisely 1.8 seconds at a time as it zooms past at 68 miles an hour into the undercarriage of the colossus roller coaster at Thorpe Park. Liberal values are under threat all over the world. Democracy is dying in the darkness. Davey, meanwhile, is now approaching the quadruple barrel roll section and his face is cracked open into the kind of open mouth grin that could easily have got him work as an extra in one flew over the cuckoo's nest. Gladstone, it hardly needs to be said, did not seek to turn the tides of history by pratfalling off a paddleboard on Lake Windermere 18 times in a row. The Afghan and Zulu wars were not denounced with the assistance of a giant inflatable log flume. But that was then, this is now. So that was Tom Peck writing in the Times
戴维的肩上。之所以难以判断，原因之一是你每次只能看到他的脸 1.8 秒，因为他正以每小时 68 英里的速度呼啸而过，冲向索普公园（Thorpe Park）巨像过山车的底盘。自由主义价值观在世界各地受到威胁。民主正在黑暗中消亡。与此同时，戴维正接近四重翻滚路段，他的脸裂开成一种大笑的表情，很容易让他去《飞越疯人院》里当个临时演员。不用说，格莱斯顿绝不会试图通过在温德米尔湖上连续 18 次从桨板上摔下来来扭转历史的潮流。阿富汗战争和祖鲁战争也不是靠巨大的充气激流勇进设施来谴责的。但那是过去，这是现在。以上是汤姆·佩克（Tom Peck）在《泰晤士报》上发表的文章，
about the breakout star, really, of the general election campaign that is currently going on in Britain. We in Britain, Dominic, will be going to the polls this time next week. So very exciting. Yeah. And I think it's fair to say it's an election campaign that seems simultaneously kind of seismic in the implications, because it seems pretty clear the Conservatives are going to lose catastrophically and Labour are going to score an absolutely massive victory. So seismic, but also boring, which is quite an odd combination. I mean, these things do happen occasionally in history. But Sir Ed Davey, who for the benefit of non-British listeners, leads the Liberal Democrats, the heirs of the party of Gladstone and Asquith, but which are really a kind of shadow of their
关于目前正在英国进行的大选中的那位真正的黑马。多米尼克，我们英国人下周这个时候就要去投票了。非常令人兴奋。是的。我认为可以公平地说，这次竞选似乎在影响上具有某种地震般的意义，因为保守党似乎注定会惨败，而工党将取得绝对性的巨大胜利。所以说它具有地震般的意义，但同时又很无聊，这真是一个奇怪的组合。我的意思是，这种事情在历史上确实偶尔会发生。但是埃德·戴维爵士（Sir Ed Davey），为了照顾非英国听众，他是自由民主党的领袖，是格莱斯顿和阿斯奎斯（Asquith）政党的继承者，但实际上只是他们
great 19th century self. Yeah. He's been trying to attract attention by staging a succession of stunts. So he's been on roller coasters. He's kind of basically fallen into late Windermere over and over again. He's ridden down a hill on a bicycle with his legs stuck out. Great fun. And we thought that today, having looked in our last episode at 18th century, 19th century
19 世纪伟大形象的影子。是的。他一直试图通过策划一系列噱头来吸引注意力。他坐过过山车。他基本上是一次又一次地掉进温德米尔湖。他双腿伸直骑着自行车冲下山坡。真有趣。我们认为，在上一集回顾了 18 世纪和 19 世纪的
political campaigning, we'd look at kind of more recent history because, Dominic, this is your mastermind subject really, isn't it? Oh, that's very kind of you, Tom. People behaving badly on election campaign trails. Yeah. So the one thing i'd say about ed davy he's just simply carrying to the extreme what politicians have done for decades so as we go through the more recent elections you know margaret thatcher harold wilson harold macmillan they all did little stunts of one kind or another and never had it so good which is my first book on british history i think there's a photograph of harold macmillan sitting on a kind of model train chugging around like a train for
政治竞选之后，我们今天应该看看更近期的历史，因为多米尼克，这确实是你的拿手好戏，不是吗？哦，你太客气了，汤姆。竞选活动中表现糟糕的人。是的。关于埃德·戴维，我想说的一点是，他只是简单地将政客们几十年来一直在做的事情推向了极端。所以当我们回顾更近期的选举时，你知道，玛格丽特·撒切尔、哈罗德·威尔逊、哈罗德·麦克米伦，他们都搞过各种各样的噱头，“从未如此美好”（Never had it so good），这是我关于英国历史的第一本书，我想书里有一张哈罗德·麦克米伦坐在一辆类似火车模型的照片，像给
toddlers so you know very incongruous image yeah because this is a man who read aeschylus in the trenches at the battle of the song exactly exactly yeah and this will be very familiar from australian canadian american politics as well yeah So in the last episode, we talked about elections when they were genuine mass participation, public civic events in which there was a lot of drinking, rowdyism, roughs, people being shot in the mouth, you know, great larks. And subsequently, what has happened is that basically elections have moved indoors and specifically indoors to radio and TV studios. So they've ceased to become mass participation events. And the question I think that hangs over election
幼儿坐的火车一样突突突地开着。所以你知道，这是一个非常不协调的画面。是的，因为这是一个在索姆河战役的战壕里读埃斯库罗斯的人。没错，没错。这在澳大利亚、加拿大和美国的政治中也会非常熟悉。是的。在上一集里，我们谈到了选举，那时它们是真正的全民参与的公共公民活动，伴随着大量的饮酒、喧闹、流氓行为，有人甚至被枪击中嘴巴，你知道，真是闹剧。后来，选举基本上转到了室内，特别是广播和电视演播室。所以它们不再是全民参与的活动。我认为悬在选举
campaigns, because that's what we're really talking about, campaigns rather than election results, is actually do they matter? Are they ever not boring? Just on the issue of boring. So one of the things that Tom Peck picks up in that passage that I read is the contrast between the kind of the heightened rhetoric of Gladstone and the pratfalling of Ed Davey. But one of the reasons for that is not just that the liberals are less likely to become a party of government. Doesn't it also reflect the fact that British politics has shrunk, that its horizons have diminished, that what Gladstone is talking about has global impact? What Ed Davey talks about, or even what Rishi Sunak or Keir Starmer talk about,
竞选——因为我们谈论的确实是竞选，而不是选举结果——之上的问题是，它们真的重要吗？它们有没有不无聊的时候？就无聊这个问题而言。汤姆·佩克在我读的那段文字中指出的其中一点，是格莱斯顿那种高调的修辞与埃德·戴维那种摔跤噱头之间的对比。但造成这种情况的原因，不仅仅是因为自由党不太可能成为执政党。这难道不也反映了英国政治已经萎缩、视野已经缩小的事实吗？格莱斯顿谈论的是具有全球影响的问题，而埃德·戴维，甚至里希·苏纳克（Rishi Sunak）或基尔·斯塔默（Keir Starmer）谈论的，
has very little global resonance at all. Well, here's the interesting thing, Tom. So what Gladstone was talking about in his most famous campaign, which was the Midlothian campaign, late 19th century, and he's giving speeches to gigantic rallies. He's talking about the Balkans, about the so-called Bulgarian atrocities. So Ottoman repression of Bulgarian nationalism in Southeastern Europe. And he's talking about a subject, you say the horizons have narrowed, but I would guess that a large proportion of Gladstone's listeners had no idea what he was talking about. I mean, not only that, by the way, an enormous proportion of Gladstone's listeners probably couldn't hear him. What I'm
几乎没有任何全球共鸣。嗯，有趣的地方就在这里，汤姆。格莱斯顿在他最著名的竞选活动——19 世纪末的米德洛锡安竞选（Midlothian campaign）——中谈论的内容，是对着巨大的集会发表演讲。他谈论的是巴尔干半岛，关于所谓的“保加利亚暴行”。也就是奥斯曼帝国对东南欧保加利亚民族主义的镇压。他谈论的是一个主题，你说视野缩小了，但我猜格莱斯顿的大部分听众根本不知道他在说什么。不仅如此，顺便说一句，格莱斯顿的大部分听众可能根本听不见他说话。我
saying is it's not just that the horizons have shrunk, they obviously have shrunk, but it's also that the context is so different. So when people turned out to those Gladstonian rallies, there would have been kind of barkers. There would have been almost like street food. It would have been a huge event, an exciting event, you know, or festival to some degree. Yeah. You know, you would be in Scotland or whatever, and you would get a chance to glimpse a great man of history. And that was tremendously exciting.
想说的是，不仅仅是视野缩小了，视野显然是缩小了，而且背景也大不相同。所以当人们参加那些格莱斯顿式的集会时，会有各种叫卖者。几乎会有街头小吃。那会是一场盛大的活动，一场令人兴奋的活动，你知道，在某种程度上是一场节日。是的。你知道，你在苏格兰或其他地方，你有机会瞥见一位伟大的历史人物。那是非常令人兴奋的。
Which had Davey with all credit to him isn't. No. But even if the prime minister were coming to your town, a lot of people wouldn't bother to turn up because the context has changed. So they've got better things to do. They've got other things to do, which people didn't in the 19th century. I suppose the equivalent would be Gaza to the Bulgarian atrocities. Yes, I guess it might be. And what British political leaders, I mean, let alone someone like Ed Davey, says about Gaza, I mean, it doesn't matter. No. Whereas what Gladstone had to say about it did
埃德·戴维，尽管我们要给他记上一功，但他并不是。不。但即使首相来到你的城镇，很多人也不会费心去参加，因为背景已经变了。所以他们有更好的事情要做。他们有其他事情要做，而 19 世纪的人们没有。我想相当于保加利亚暴行的现代版本可能是加沙问题。是的，我想可能是吧。而英国政治领导人——更不用说像埃德·戴维这样的人——对加沙的看法，我的意思是，这并不重要。不。而格莱斯顿对它的看法确实
matter. And I just wonder whether that kind of diminishes the sense of excitement, the sense of occasion, the sense that great issues are at play. Possibly. Although that said, I don't believe that foreign policy has ever really mattered to the British people or that it's had a massive impact on domestic elections. And if you want the prime example of that, look at the 2005 election, two years after Tony Blair invaded Iraq, and he wins a big majority. And there's a sense that even though people vaguely talk about it in that campaign, that ultimately a large number of the British population just simply don't care one way or the other. Yeah.
很重要。我只是想知道，这种感觉是否削弱了兴奋感、仪式感，以及那种重大问题正在上演的感觉。可能吧。尽管如此，我不认为外交政策对英国人民真正重要，或者它对国内选举产生了巨大的影响。如果你想要最典型的例子，看看 2005 年的选举，托尼·布莱尔入侵伊拉克两年后，他赢得了多数席位。尽管人们在竞选中模糊地谈论它，但最终很大一部分英国民众根本不在乎。是的。
I mean, I suppose you could say the classic example of that actually would be 1945, which is obviously coming off the victory in the Second World War, in which Churchill obviously had been the war leader, and he loses spectacularly. So let's start with 1945, because I think that's the first really canonical national election. It's almost like 1945 is when most people's electoral memory starts. So the way that election worked was that the national governments that had taken us into the war broke up at the end of May. There's an election on the 5th of July. But then because so many people are abroad, obviously, in the army,
我的意思是，我想你可以说最经典的例子其实是 1945 年，那显然是在第二次世界大战胜利之后，丘吉尔显然是战时领袖，但他惨败了。所以让我们从 1945 年开始，因为我认为那是第一次真正意义上的全国性选举。几乎可以说 1945 年是大多数人选举记忆的起点。所以那次选举的运作方式是，带领我们进入战争的联合政府在 5 月底解散了。7 月 5 日举行选举。但因为很多人都在国外，显然是在军队里，
it takes a long time to cancel the vote, so the result doesn't come through until weeks later. And actually, if you look at that campaign, there's really only one incident from the campaign worthy of any comment, which is they made radio speeches, Churchill and the Labour leader Clement Attlee. Churchill made what's often regarded as one of the sort of landmark gaffes in an election campaign where he said, if there was a Labour government, a socialist government in Britain, they would need, and I quote, some form of Gestapo, no doubt very humanely directed in
统计选票需要很长时间，所以结果直到几周后才出来。实际上，如果你看那次竞选，竞选中只有一件事值得评论，那就是他们发表了广播演讲，丘吉尔和工党领袖克莱门特·艾德礼（Clement Attlee）。丘吉尔发表了通常被认为是竞选活动中标志性失言之一的言论，他说，如果英国有一个工党政府，一个社会主义政府，他们将需要，我引用，“某种形式的盖世太保，毫无疑问在
the first instance. And a lot of people said, this is incredibly tasteless. Like you're talking about the people who've been sitting around you fighting the Gestapo. And to say that the National Health Service or Better Pensions would necessarily involve a secret police organisation is obviously ludicrous. But the thing is, it's very hard to measure that. We know from people's diaries and stuff that they thought this was a bit much. But opinion polling in 1945 is really in its infancy. Right. And you need opinion polls, don't you? Because it's kind of the equivalent of tracking the score in a test match or something. Exactly. So our sense of election campaigns as narratives, as stories, or as roller coasters,
最初阶段是非常人道地指导的”。很多人说，这太没品了。就像你在谈论那些一直和你并肩作战对抗盖世太保的人。说国民医疗服务体系或更好的养老金必然涉及秘密警察组织，这显然是荒谬的。但问题是，这很难衡量。我们从人们的日记之类的东西中知道，他们认为这有点过分了。但 1945 年的民意调查确实还处于起步阶段。对。你需要民意调查，不是吗？因为这有点像在板球比赛中追踪比分之类的。没错。所以我们对作为叙事、故事或过山车的选举竞选的理解，
which really comes from America, was imported into Britain in the 1960s after Kennedy beat Nixon in a televised election that did arouse some interest in Britain, probably the first American election that most people in Britain actually ever noticed. And from that point, you get this sense of the horse race. You know, it's a race. Between two leaders. Yeah. Now, people never really talked of it as a race in Britain before that. They talked about campaigns as a chance to mobilize your voters. But I think there was a general assumption that the result was probably determined before you started the campaign, and the campaign was just a sort of jamboree
这实际上来自美国，是在 1960 年代肯尼迪在电视选举中击败尼克松之后引入英国的，那次选举确实在英国引起了一些兴趣，可能是大多数英国人真正注意到的第一次美国选举。从那时起，你就有了这种“赛马”的感觉。你知道，这是一场比赛。在两位领导人之间。是的。现在，在那之前，人们在英国从未真正把它当作一场比赛来谈论。他们谈论竞选是动员选民的机会。但我认为当时有一个普遍的假设，即结果可能在竞选开始前就已经决定了，竞选只是某种狂欢，
in which you got your voters excited and made sure they would go to the polls. But most people have probably made up their minds, which actually, I think, is a better way of thinking about it than the horse race idea in Britain. So if you look at 1945, the mystique, the myth of it, is that because it's a landmark election that sees Labour win, that therefore people must have been really enthused and excited
在狂欢中你让选民兴奋起来，并确保他们会去投票。但大多数人可能已经拿定了主意，这实际上我认为比英国的“赛马”概念更好。所以如果你看 1945 年，它的神秘感、神话在于，因为它是一场见证工党获胜的里程碑式选举，所以人们一定非常热情和兴奋，
that maybe this is a lost golden age of elections where people really cared. And yet, if you read the best book on this, which is David Kynaston's Austerity Britain, he has some wonderful examples in that of people just saying, no one cares. George Orwell, who's obviously really into his politics, says that when he was in London, he never heard a single person remark about it.
也许这是一个选举的失落黄金时代，人们真的关心。然而，如果你读关于这个问题的最好的书，也就是大卫·凯纳斯顿（David Kynaston）的《紧缩的英国》（Austerity Britain），他在书中引用了一些精彩的例子，人们只是说，没人关心。乔治·奥威尔（George Orwell），他显然非常热衷于政治，他说当他在伦敦时，他从未听到过一个人谈论这件事。
He said that he saw election posters, but people walked past them as though they weren't there. And Kynaston has these wonderful sort of very 1940s quotes of people saying, I don't take any interest in the election. Not a scrap. To me, it's an awful lot of Tommy rot with each party running the other one down. I don't know who I'll vote for. I don't like politicians anyway. They're all crooks.
他说他看到了竞选海报，但人们走过它们时就像没看见一样。凯纳斯顿引用了一些非常 1940 年代的语录，人们说：“我对选举不感兴趣。一点也不。对我来说，这全是废话，每个政党都在诋毁对方。我不知道我会投给谁。反正我不喜欢政客。他们都是骗子。”
You can imagine them, can't you? Absolutely. Kind of lovable types from Ealing comedies. Exactly. In their demob suits. So people who listened
你能想象他们，对吧？绝对是。来自伊灵喜剧（Ealing comedies）中那种可爱的类型。没错。穿着他们的复员西装。所以听过
to our previous episode will know that the people of Coventry had a history of behaving poorly in elections because it was in Coventry that they had turned out with howlbirds.
我们上一集的人会知道，考文垂人民在选举中表现不佳是有历史的，因为正是在考文垂，他们带着戟出现了。
Great days. And I think I see the 1698 to 1705 and they'd seized the Guildhall and they said they would eat the wigs. Yeah. But in Coventry in 1945, our sources say basically no one has any interest at all. And the crowds only turn out when Churchill comes to visit. But the interesting thing here is many of these people are Labour voters and they've turned out because they want to see the big man, like your Gladstone thing, Tom. Yeah. A big celebrity has come to town. it. But the interesting thing here is many of these people are Labour voters and they've turned
美好的日子。我想我看到 1698 年到 1705 年，他们占领了市政厅，说他们要吃掉假发。是的。但在 1945 年的考文垂，我们的资料显示基本上没人有任何兴趣。人群只有在丘吉尔来访时才会出现。但这里有趣的是，这些人中有许多是工党选民，他们出现是因为他们想看大人物，就像你说的格莱斯顿那样，汤姆。是的。一位大名人来到了镇上。但这里有趣的是，这些人中有许多是工党选民，他们出现是因为他们想看大人物，就像你说的格莱斯顿那样，汤姆。一位大名人来到了镇上。所以就像你比作节日一样？是的。你知道，你去参加节日是因为有大牌明星压轴之类的。没错。现在，工党在 1945 年赢得了非常大的多数，146 席的多数。人们普遍认为他们获胜是因为他们有更积极的建设和平的计划。保守党并没有什么特别建设性的东西可以提供。
out because they want to see the big man, like your Gladstone thing, Tom. A big celebrity has come to town. So like your comparison to a festival? Yeah. You know, you go to a festival because there's a massive act headlining or something. Exactly. Now, Labour win a very big majority in 1945, a majority of 146. And it's generally accepted that they win this because they have a much more positive plan for building the peace. The Tories don't really have anything terribly constructive to offer.
因为他们想见大人物，就像你提到的格莱斯顿那样，汤姆。一位大名人来到了城里。所以就像你把它比作节日一样？是的。你知道，你去参加节日是因为有重量级嘉宾压轴之类的。没错。1945年工党赢得了非常大的多数席位，多数优势为146席。人们普遍认为他们获胜是因为他们有更积极的战后重建计划。保守党并没有什么特别建设性的提议。
The long-standing middle-class fear of Labour, which is they're unpatriotic, they won't spend money on defence, all these kinds of things, that's been completely diffused because, of course, Labour have been in the national government that's won the war. Major Attlee.
长期以来中产阶级对工党的恐惧，即他们不爱国，他们不会在国防上花钱，所有这些事情，都已经完全消散了，因为当然，工党一直在赢得战争的联合政府中。艾德礼少校。
Major Attlee. People are very used to Attlee and his comrades. So Labour win a big majority. But you can argue, and I think this sets the tone for what follows, that A, for most people, even if they're pleased with the result, they actually didn't really like having politics in the newspapers. They found the whole thing very boring. They're not anything like as enthusiastic as later mythology suggests.
艾德礼少校。人们非常习惯艾德礼和他的同志们。所以工党赢得了大多数。但你可以争辩，我认为这为随后的事情定下了基调，即 A，对大多数人来说，即使他们对结果感到高兴，他们实际上并不喜欢在报纸上看到政治。他们觉得整件事非常无聊。他们一点也不像后来的神话所暗示的那样热情。
And number two, had they never bothered to campaign but just all gone on a massive holiday to Butlins or something, it's kind of Westminster outing. Instead, basically done an Ed Davey. If they hadn't campaigned, the result would probably have been exactly the same. So this is the question, isn't it? How many election campaigns does the campaigning make a difference to? Are there any? I would say generally it doesn't matter unless it does. This is the top punditry we want from Britain's leading historian of modern Britain.
第二，如果他们从未费心去竞选，而是全都去布特林斯（Butlins）度假之类的，这就像是威斯敏斯特的郊游。相反，基本上做了埃德·戴维做的事。如果他们没有竞选，结果可能完全一样。所以这就是问题所在，不是吗？有多少选举竞选是竞选本身起了作用的？有吗？我会说通常它不重要，除非它重要。这就是我们从英国领先的现代英国历史学家那里得到的顶级评论。
Yeah. So if you go through all the 50s and 60s elections, for example, those election campaigns, you know, I've written about them. I've spent, you know, unhealthily large quantities of my life, of my time on this planet, thinking about the 1966 election or 1964, 1959. But they're non-events actually, Tom. And they're partly non-events because until the 60s, obviously most people don't have television. So they're experiencing it only through the radio or their newspapers.
是的。所以如果你回顾 50 年代和 60 年代的所有选举，例如，那些竞选活动，你知道，我写过它们。我花了我这辈子不健康的大量时间思考 1966 年或 1964 年、1959 年的选举。但它们实际上是非事件，汤姆。它们部分是非事件，因为直到 60 年代，显然大多数人没有电视。所以他们只能通过广播或报纸来体验。
And they're experiencing it very much at one remove. Most people don't go to rallies. They don't go to meetings. They have at best a kind of mild interest, but all the coverage generally says, what a terribly boring and underwhelming campaign this is, and that most people are completely apathetic and unenthused by it. And it's a stereotype of how the media cover it, that it's kind of,
他们体验得非常疏离。大多数人不去集会。他们不去参加会议。他们充其量只有一种轻微的兴趣，但所有的报道通常都说，这是一场多么无聊和令人失望的竞选，大多数人对此完全冷漠和不感兴趣。媒体报道它的刻板印象是，它有点像，
Prime Minister, would you care to list any more of your achievements? Yeah. Is that a stereotype or not? I think that's pretty fair. I think interviewers, they won't give anything like the same number of interviews as they do today. They'd give one or two. And the tone is not, let's catch them out. There's no sense of that. Yeah. why are these lying bastards lying to me yeah exactly that i think dates from the 60s that phrase but actually really the tone is very deferential the politicians if you watch those interviews mcmillan wilson heath whoever they give quite long answers quite thoughtful answers
“首相，您愿意列举更多您的成就吗？”是的。那是刻板印象吗？我认为这很公平。我认为采访者，他们不会像今天这样提供同样数量的采访。他们会给一两次。而且语气不是“让我们抓住他们的把柄”。没有那种感觉。是的。“为什么这些撒谎的混蛋在对我撒谎？”是的，没错，我认为那个短语可以追溯到 60 年代，但实际上语气非常恭敬。政客们，如果你看那些采访，麦克米伦、威尔逊、希思，无论谁，他们给出的答案都很长，很深思熟虑，
reflective there's no sense of them being on their guard particularly or much less of a sense. They're not worried about being tripped up unless they say something really stupid. They can change their mind during an answer. And actually, they have a message about themselves and about their opponents that they want to project, but there's no sense of them having rehearsed lines. And actually, that is an American campaign technique. It was really pioneered by Nixon in 1968. There's a brilliant book by Joe McGuinness. I think it's called The Selling of the President or something about how Nixon used Californian ad men to hone his campaign,
反思性很强。没有那种他们特别警惕的感觉，或者那种感觉少得多。他们不担心被绊倒，除非他们说了什么真的很蠢的话。他们可以在回答过程中改变主意。实际上，他们有一个关于自己和对手的信息想要传达，但没有那种他们排练过台词的感觉。实际上，这是一种美国的竞选技巧。它确实是由尼克松在 1968 年开创的。有一本很棒的书，乔·麦金尼斯（Joe McGuinness）写的，我想叫《总统的推销》（The Selling of the President）之类的，关于尼克松如何利用加州的广告人来磨练他的竞选，
to hammer a particular message again and again in particular lines. And this is the first time it happens? Yeah. I mean, people have done it kind of accidentally, but never in such a kind of systematic, ruthless, cold-blooded way. And British politics is very, very slow to catch up with that and probably only catches up with that really in the 1980s, I would say. There's great banter, isn't there, in the 1964 election where Harold Wilson laughs at the Conservative leader who is the 13th Lord Home.
一遍又一遍地用特定的台词来强化一个特定的信息。这是第一次发生这种情况吗？是的。我的意思是，人们可能偶然做过，但从未以这种系统、无情、冷血的方式做过。英国政治在追赶这一点上非常非常缓慢，我可以说可能直到 1980 年代才真正赶上。1964 年的选举中有很多精彩的调侃，不是吗？哈罗德·威尔逊嘲笑保守党领袖，也就是第 13 代霍姆伯爵（Lord Home）。
Yes. And makes great play with this. And he's casting himself as meritocratic and go ahead and everything. Yeah. And Alec Douglas Holmes says, well, I suppose that Mr. Wilson is the 13th Mr. Wilson. Yeah. And that's tremendous cut and thrust. Great repartee.
是的。并且大做文章。他把自己塑造成精英管理、积极进取等等。是的。而亚历克·道格拉斯-霍姆（Alec Douglas-Home）说，好吧，我想威尔逊先生是第 13 位威尔逊先生。是的。那真是精彩的交锋。伟大的机智。
Yeah. Well, to be fair to Harold Wilson. So Harold Wilson made a previous appearance in our podcast when we did Britain in 1974. And he came over very... Shabby. Yeah. He came over in very shabby. Yeah, he came over in a shabby manner. Shopworn. Shopworn. But in 1964, he wasn't shopworn at all. And actually, when you look at that campaign, it's quite tight, the result. Labour get in,
是的。好吧，公平地说，哈罗德·威尔逊。哈罗德·威尔逊之前在我们的播客中出现过，当时我们做的是 1974 年的英国。他表现得非常……邋遢。是的。他表现得非常邋遢。是的。他表现得非常邋遢。陈旧。陈旧。但在 1964 年，他一点也不陈旧。实际上，当你回顾那场竞选时，结果非常接近。工党进入了，
but by much smaller margin than they had anticipated. Go on, Tom. Because this was the kind of the model for what the Conservatives were hoping would happen this time, that they were way behind. And then under Alec Douglas' home, they claw it back, don't they? Yeah. Which has significantly failed to happen this time. Exactly. But actually, look at that campaign. So they have mass rallies still.
但幅度比他们预期的要小得多。继续，汤姆。因为这是保守党这次希望发生的那种模式，他们远远落后。然后在亚历克·道格拉斯-霍姆的领导下，他们扳回了一局，不是吗？是的。这次明显没有发生这种情况。没错。但实际上，看看那场竞选。所以他们仍然有群众集会。
So Wilson would go and address a big meeting in a town hall. And what is totally different from today is that in the 1960s, the crowd would be very mixed. You know, he's speaking. There are people shouting, rubbish. You're going to put up our taxes, Mr. Wilson, or something like this. And he, Wilson, was brilliant at dealing with hecklers.lers now that's something that most modern politicians are totally incapable of doing because they've never had to do it they've always been in a manicured environment but in
所以威尔逊会去市政厅发表大型演讲。与今天完全不同的是，在 1960 年代，人群会非常混杂。你知道，他在演讲。有人在喊，“垃圾。你要提高我们的税收，威尔逊先生，或者类似的话。”而他，威尔逊，非常擅长对付质问者。现在这是大多数现代政客完全无法做到的，因为他们从未不得不这样做，他们一直处于修剪整齐的环境中。但在
those labor campaigns there could be people throwing things there could be people making jokes and Wilson is really good he's always got a nice little line he's never sort of phased on the platform he's relaxed he's funny but again I don't think the campaign massively changes people's minds. Okay. So on the thing of Wilson against Heath, who then follows out of his home to become conservative leader, and they just keep endlessly fighting elections against each other. The one that people say there is a difference is in 1970, where Wilson and Labour are expected to win, and then England crash out of the World Cup. Yeah, I love this. Unexpectedly, having been 2-0 up with what, kind of 10 minutes
那些工党竞选中，可能会有人扔东西，可能会有人开玩笑，而威尔逊真的很棒，他总是有很好的台词，他在讲台上从不慌乱，他很放松，他很有趣，但我仍然认为竞选并没有大规模地改变人们的想法。好的。关于威尔逊对阵希思，后者随后接替道格拉斯-霍姆成为保守党领袖，他们只是不断地互相竞选。人们说有区别的一次是 1970 年，当时威尔逊和工党被认为会赢，然后英格兰在世界杯中出局了。是的，我喜欢这个。出乎意料，在还剩什么，大约 10 分钟
to go or something. Yeah, I think maybe a quarter of the match left. So Alf Ramsey, the manager, took off Bobby Charlton. England had a better team in 1970 than they did in 1966. The World Cup is in Mexico. England are defending the World Cup. They're generally expected to win. they're 2-0 up against the Germans, and then the Germans end up winning 3-2, and that is four days before polling day. So in that campaign, Wilson had been in Paris in 64, he'd had a very, very rocky time in government, had to devalue the pound, all kinds of things, you know, great sense of sort of disappointment and frustration about his government. And yet, Heath is regarded as so dreadful, as such a poor performer, that everyone thinks Wilson is going to win really easily. And actually, Wilson does something that had not been done before. So Wilson goes on walkabouts.
的时候，2-0 领先。是的，我想可能比赛还剩四分之一。所以阿尔夫·拉姆齐（Alf Ramsey），教练，换下了博比·查尔顿（Bobby Charlton）。英格兰在 1970 年的球队比 1966 年更好。世界杯在墨西哥。英格兰是卫冕冠军。他们通常被认为会赢。他们 2-0 领先德国人，然后德国人最终 3-2 获胜，那是在投票日前四天。所以在那场竞选中，威尔逊在 64 年去过巴黎，他在政府中度过了一段非常非常艰难的时期，不得不让英镑贬值，各种各样的事情，你知道，对他政府的失望和沮丧感很强。然而，希思被认为太糟糕了，表现太差了，以至于每个人都认为威尔逊会很容易获胜。实际上，威尔逊做了一件以前没做过的事。所以威尔逊去走访了。
I mean, we're very familiar with that now. It's a lovely summer in 1970. So he's in his kind of shirt sleeves, and he walks around town centres, like, shaking hands with random people. How do you do? Lovely to see you. I'm Howard Wilson. Please vote for the Labour Party. And no one had done that before? Not really. So American politicians had done it and the Queen did it on a Commonwealth tour, I think of Australia a year or so earlier. I love to think the Queen is blazing a path. That's it. The Queen is a great innovator. I mean, Wilson and the Queen got on like house on fire, didn't they? Wilson loved the Queen. He was her favourite Prime Minister by all accounts. So Wilson copies the Queen got on like house on fire, didn't they? Wilson loved the Queen. He was her favourite Prime Minister, by all accounts. So Wilson copies the Queen.
我的意思是，我们现在非常熟悉了。1970 年夏天很可爱。所以他穿着衬衫袖子，在市中心走来走去，比如，和随机的人握手。“你好吗？很高兴见到你。我是哈罗德·威尔逊。请投票给工党。”以前没人做过吗？不完全是。所以美国政客做过，女王在英联邦巡回访问时做过，我想是一年前左右在澳大利亚。我喜欢认为女王开辟了一条道路。就是这样。女王是一位伟大的创新者。我的意思是，威尔逊和女王相处得像火一样，不是吗？威尔逊爱女王。据所有报道，她是她最喜欢的首相。所以威尔逊复制了女王相处得像火一样，不是吗？威尔逊爱女王。据所有报道，她是她最喜欢的首相。所以威尔逊复制了女王。
He basically wants to take politics out of it and run a kind of smiling presidential campaign and coast to victory against Heath. And actually, when he loses unexpectedly, Heath won by 30 seats. Wilson said, oh, well, it was the football, of course, that cost us. There was a feel-bad factor. I think that's nonsense. There was a bad set of trade figures just before the election, which was much more important.
他基本上想把政治从竞选中剔除，进行一种微笑的总统式竞选，并轻松击败希思。实际上，当他意外落败时，希思赢了 30 个席位。威尔逊说，哦，好吧，当然是足球让我们付出了代价。有一种感觉不好的因素。我认为那是胡说八道。选举前有一组糟糕的贸易数据，这重要得多。
And actually, I think what those bad trade figures did was they reminded people that Wilson had not been a terribly good steward of the economy, and they kind of reinforced existing anxieties. And he'd let the Beatles break up. That's um... So, yeah, all kinds of reasons. Yeah, you always say that about Harold Wilson.
实际上，我认为那些糟糕的贸易数据所做的是提醒人们，威尔逊并不是一个非常好的经济管家，它们强化了现有的焦虑。而且他让披头士乐队解散了。那是……所以，是的，各种各样的原因。是的，你总是那样说哈罗德·威尔逊。
I think that's very harsh. I think you're attributing him with more power than he... He should have stepped in. Yeah. So Heath wins that one. And then people have listened to our 1974 series where we talk about the two elections of that year in which Heath manages to lose both of them. Yeah.
我认为这太苛刻了。我认为你赋予他的权力比他……他应该介入的。是的。所以希思赢了那一次。然后人们听了我们 1974 年的系列节目，我们谈到了那一年的两次选举，希思设法输掉了两次。是的。
He was a terrible performer, wasn't he? We had more liberal shenanigans with Jeremy Thorpe. So 1974, I know we can't go into it because we did a whole series on that, but we have Hovercraft, we have Jeremy Thorpe, IRA 1974, I know we can't go into it because we did a whole series on that, but we have Hovercraft, we have Jeremy Thorpe, IRA bombs. Enoch Powell. If you listen to our series on 1974, which you can find on the Rest Is History
他表现得很糟糕，不是吗？我们有更多杰里米·索普（Jeremy Thorpe）的自由党闹剧。所以 1974 年，我知道我们不能深入探讨，因为我们做了一个完整的系列节目，但我们有气垫船，我们有杰里米·索普，爱尔兰共和军 1974 年，我知道我们不能深入探讨，因为我们做了一个完整的系列节目，但我们有气垫船，我们有杰里米·索普，爱尔兰共和军
sort of page if you scroll down it, you will hear competing impersonations of Enoch Powell and discussions of Howard Wilson's staff trying to murder his secretary. So enjoy it. So, you know, if 1970s elections are your thing,
炸弹。伊诺克·鲍威尔（Enoch Powell）。如果你听我们关于 1974 年的系列节目，你可以在《历史的余味》页面上找到它，如果你向下滚动，你会听到对伊诺克·鲍威尔的模仿竞争，以及关于哈罗德·威尔逊的工作人员试图谋杀他的秘书的讨论。所以享受吧。所以，你知道，如果 1970 年代的选举是你的菜，
the 1974 series, you'll be absolutely in clover. But just moving on to the election after that 1979, which sees Mrs. Thatcher come to power and defeat James Callaghan. There's a famous thing that James Callaghan is supposed to have said, and I'm sure you'll tell me he didn't say it, but Callaghan feels that the polls are against him, that the Tories seem to be closing in, and he's meant to have said to his aide, is it Bernard Donoghue? Yeah. And they're kind of driving around Parliament Square. And he says that there are times, kind of like every 30 years, when there is a sea change in politics and that this sea change is
1974 年的系列节目，你绝对会非常喜欢。但继续谈谈那之后的选举，1979 年，撒切尔夫人上台并击败了詹姆斯·卡拉汉（James Callaghan）。詹姆斯·卡拉汉据说说过一句名言，我相信你会告诉我他没说过，但卡拉汉觉得民调对他不利，保守党似乎正在逼近，他本意是告诉他的助手，是伯纳德·多诺霍（Bernard Donoghue）吗？是的。他们开车绕过议会广场。他说，有些时候，大约每 30 年，政治中就会发生一次巨变，而这种巨变
now working to the benefit of Mrs. Thatcher. Yeah. Do you think that's accurate? Do you think there are kind of rhythms in politics? Because I know you're a great admirer of James Callaghan. He has no greater admirer, Tom. I know. I love this election because I actually like both party leaders. I can't lose. Brilliant. It's great. So first of all, did he say that? And do you think that he's onto something when he says that?
现在正朝着有利于撒切尔夫人的方向发展。是的。你认为这准确吗？你认为政治中存在某种节奏吗？因为我知道你是詹姆斯·卡拉汉的崇拜者。汤姆，他没有比这更大的崇拜者了。我知道。我喜欢这次选举，因为我实际上喜欢两位政党领袖。我不会输。太棒了。这太棒了。所以首先，他说了吗？你认为当他说这话时，他是否发现了什么？
First of all, he's definitely onto something. There are generational shifts. I mean, we could talk about this in great detail. My friend Phil Tinline has written a book called The Death of Consensus, which is all about this, which is all about how every 30 years or so there is a generational shift and there's a sense of the taboo shifting, the center ground shifting. The Overton window. The Overton window, as people call it. Exactly so. Callaghan did say something like it, but he didn't say what everyone thinks he said. Right. So here's the interesting thing. And I think I'm the first person or the only person to have noticed this. Brilliant. So in Bernard Donoghue's memoir of that conversation, he
首先，他绝对发现了什么。存在代际转变。我的意思是，我们可以详细谈谈这个。我的朋友菲尔·廷莱恩（Phil Tinline）写了一本书叫《共识的死亡》（The Death of Consensus），全是关于这个的，全是关于每 30 年左右就会发生一次代际转变，以及禁忌转变、中间地带转变的感觉。奥弗顿之窗（Overton window）。正如人们所说，奥弗顿之窗。完全正确。卡拉汉确实说过类似的话，但他没有说每个人认为他说的那些话。对。所以有趣的地方在这里。而且我认为我是第一个或唯一一个注意到这一点的人。太棒了。在伯纳德·多诺霍关于那次谈话的回忆录中，他
absolutely says, Callaghan said to him, oh, we're not going to win. There's a sea change, Bernard, and you know, blah, blah, blah. Nothing you can say or do will make any difference. But actually, if you look at Bernard Donoghue's diary, which I did, which is also published, but nobody's bothered, as far as I'm aware, to compare the two. He doesn't say that. In the diary, which was compiled closer to the time, Callaghan says, I'm actually feeling really good about the election. I think we actually might win this or do a lot better than people think, unless there has been a sea change, right? So in other words, Callaghan was feeling much more optimistic. There's a couple of interesting things here. Number one is a lot of people say 79 is a great missed opportunity for Labour
绝对说，卡拉汉对他说，“哦，我们不会赢。有一场巨变，伯纳德，你知道，等等等等。你说什么或做什么都不会有任何区别。”但实际上，如果你看伯纳德·多诺霍的日记，我看了，它也出版了，但据我所知，没有人费心去比较这两者。他没那么说。在日记中，它是更接近那个时间编写的，卡拉汉说，“我实际上对选举感觉很好。我认为我们实际上可能会赢，或者比人们想象的做得好得多，除非发生了巨变，对吧？”所以换句话说，卡拉汉当时感觉乐观得多。这里有几件有趣的事情。第一，很多人说 79 年是工党错失的巨大机会，
because Callaghan put that election off and had he held it earlier, before the great wave of strikes of the winter discontent, then he might have won and nobody would ever have heard of Margaret Thatcher. Because he goes to the party conference the previous autumn, doesn't he, in 1978, and sings a song, There Was I Waiting at the Church. It's actually the TUC conference, the trade unions. It's just a musical song that no one knows what it means. Yeah, this is the age of the sex pistols.
因为卡拉汉推迟了那次选举，如果他早点举行，在“不满之冬”的大罢工浪潮之前，那么他可能就赢了，没人会听说玛格丽特·撒切尔。因为他前一年秋天，也就是 1978 年，去了党代会，不是吗？唱了一首歌，《我在教堂等待》（There Was I Waiting at the Church）。实际上是工会大会（TUC conference）。这只是一首没人知道是什么意思的音乐歌曲。是的，这是性手枪乐队（Sex Pistols）的时代。
Yeah, he led everybody up the garden path thinking there'd be an election, then he put it off. I know why he put it off. He put it off because all the data showed him that he wouldn't win it. Or at least if he did win it, it'd be so narrow that it would make his life a total misery. Gordon Brown did something similar, didn't he? Which also was then a shadow over him because there was a feeling that he'd bottled it. I don't think Callaghan bottled it.
是的，他把每个人都带进了花园小径，以为会有选举，然后他推迟了。我知道他为什么推迟。他推迟是因为所有数据都显示他赢不了。或者至少如果他赢了，也会非常微弱，以至于会让他的生活变得极其痛苦。戈登·布朗（Gordon Brown）也做了类似的事，不是吗？这也成了他的阴影，因为人们觉得他退缩了。我不认为卡拉汉退缩了。
I think he just made a call that, you know, we're probably not going to win the 78. We'll go for a break in 79 and he loses anyway. Because there was a feeling, when was it? So I guess 2009. Yeah. That Gordon Brown had bottled it, that he'd planned to have an election and then didn't. Well, he'd planned to have an election in 2007, Tom, after he'd just come in. And that would have been the moment to have it before the financial crash.
我认为他只是做了一个判断，你知道，我们可能赢不了 78 年。我们会在 79 年休息一下，但他还是输了。因为有一种感觉，是什么时候？所以我想是 2009 年。是的。戈登·布朗退缩了，他计划举行选举，然后没有。好吧，他计划在 2007 年举行选举，汤姆，在他刚上任后。那将是在金融危机之前举行选举的时刻。
Oh, right. That's it. Yes, I'm misremembering. But by the time Callaghan does go to the country in 79, I think that election is a bit of a foregone conclusion. The winter of discontent has happened. There's a big shift to Thatcher among working class people, among young first-time voters. They break overwhelmingly for Thatcher in 79. There's a couple of really fun things about that election. So in the public imagination, this is the great ideological showdown between Labour and conservatism, where Thatcherism arrives.
哦，对了。就是这样。是的，我记错了。但当卡拉汉在 79 年真正去参加选举时，我认为那次选举有点像既定事实。不满之冬已经发生了。在工人阶级中，在年轻的首次选民中，向撒切尔的转变很大。他们在 79 年压倒性地投向了撒切尔。关于那次选举有几件非常有趣的事情。所以在大众想象中，这是工党和保守党之间伟大的意识形态对决，撒切尔主义到来了。
And some people, to be fair, at the time did say this. So are you familiar with the satirist Oberon Waugh? I am. Evelyn Waugh's son wrote a column in Private Eye. He did. I think it was in that column or was it in the Spectator? I'm not sure which. This reads like it's from his column in Private Eye because, I mean, he was a very kind of
有些人，公平地说，当时确实这么说。所以你熟悉讽刺作家奥伯伦·沃（Oberon Waugh）吗？我熟悉。伊夫林·沃（Evelyn Waugh）的儿子在《私家侦探》（Private Eye）杂志上写专栏。他写过。我想是在那个专栏里，还是在《旁观者》（Spectator）里？我不确定是哪个。这读起来就像是他《私家侦探》专栏里的内容，因为，我的意思是，他是一个非常……
reactionary, crusty, well, I mean, you know, he's the son of Evelyn Waugh. Yeah. But in this column that he wrote for Private Eye, he would exaggerate that to kind of comically grotesque gargantuan degree yeah he said in who's who i think that his hobby was telling lies yeah so in this he says this is the showdown now he says this is the chance this is the battle against the other sides and i quote and i apologize to our listeners if any are going to be offended by this. He says, they're dwarves, they're ugly women, young men with squints and crooked minds, victims of broken homes or comprehensive education with impassive faces and staring eyes. The other side's hunchbacks, sexual incompetence, militant feminists,
反动、顽固的，好吧，我的意思是，你知道，他是伊夫林·沃的儿子。是的。但在他为《私家侦探》写的这个专栏里，他会把那种程度夸张到一种滑稽的怪诞程度，是的，他在《名人录》（Who's Who）里说，我想他的爱好是撒谎。是的，所以在这里他说，这是对决，现在他说，这是机会，这是对抗另一方的战斗，我引用，如果有人会被冒犯，我向我们的听众道歉。他说，“他们是侏儒，他们是丑陋的女人，斜视和思想扭曲的年轻人，破碎家庭或综合教育的受害者，面无表情，眼神呆滞。另一方是驼背、性无能、激进的女权主义者，”
baby bashers, trade unionists, teachers, lesbians, drunks, freaks, idlers, social workers, new statesman journalists, and Islington housewives. So presumably he's talking about Labour there, I'm guessing. He's talking about Labour. And yet the thing is, the public actually didn't agree with him at all because they didn't think there was any difference between the two parties. I mean, that's the amazing irony. But wouldn't you argue that essentially there wasn't?
婴儿破坏者、工会成员、教师、女同性恋者、酒鬼、怪胎、游手好闲者、社会工作者、新政治家杂志的记者，以及伊斯灵顿的家庭主妇。所以大概他在那里谈论的是工党，我猜。他在谈论工党。然而事实是，公众根本不同意他的观点，因为他们认为这两个政党之间没有任何区别。我的意思是，这真是极大的讽刺。但你难道不会认为本质上确实没有区别吗？
Isn't that the Sandbrookian take? Yeah. That the Labour government has laid the foundations for Thatcherism? It has. Yeah, I do make that argument, Tom. With Dennis Healy and Callaghan? Tom, good knowledge. Good knowledge.
那不是桑德布鲁克式的观点吗？是的。工党政府为撒切尔主义奠定了基础？确实如此。是的，汤姆，我确实提出了这个论点。和丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy）以及卡拉汉（Callaghan）一起？汤姆，知识渊博。知识渊博。
I've read your books, Dominic. So actually five out of 10 people didn't think there were any important differences between the Conservatives and Labour. In other words, people think they are closer together than pretty much any time since the Second World War, which is extraordinary. Yeah. The other interesting thing is that Thatcher is a real novelty, of course. And Callaghan feels he can't really go at her because she's a woman and he doesn't want to look on gallants.
多米尼克，我读过你的书。事实上，十分之五的人认为保守党和工党之间没有任何重要的区别。换句话说，人们认为他们比二战以来的任何时候都更接近，这太不可思议了。是的。另一个有趣的事情是，撒切尔当然是一个真正的新奇事物。而卡拉汉觉得他不能真正攻击她，因为她是个女人，他不想显得不绅士。
It's the first time a woman has been in that position. And there's definitely a sense, I think, of Callaghan in particular, I would say, pulling his punches. Because he's an old school gent. In the House of Commons, he'd always patronised Mrs Thatcher. I think at one point he actually called her the little lady. But on the campaign trail, he's been told, don't condescend to her because that'll lose your support among women. So he basically is just avuncular and, you know,
这是第一次有女性处于那个位置。我认为，特别是卡拉汉，有一种他正在收敛锋芒的感觉。因为他是一位老派绅士。在下议院，他总是对撒切尔夫人表现出居高临下的态度。我想有一次他甚至称她为“小女士”。但在竞选活动中，有人告诉他，不要对她表现出屈尊俯就，因为那会让你失去女性选民的支持。所以他基本上只是表现得像个和蔼的长辈，你知道的，
like she's a sort of amusing niece. Yes, who's come back from university with unexpected opinions. Exactly, exactly. She's got her radical opinions. I don't agree with them, but I admire her enthusiasm. But interestingly, he's much more popular than she is. The further the campaign goes on, the more people like him and don't like her. So his lead over her stretched from 7% to 19% as the campaign went on.
就像她是某个有趣的侄女。是的，从大学回来带着意想不到的观点。没错，没错。她有她激进的观点。我不同意，但我钦佩她的热情。但有趣的是，他比她受欢迎得多。竞选活动进行得越久，人们就越喜欢他而不喜欢她。随着竞选的进行，他领先她的优势从7%扩大到了19%。
And amazingly, four out of 10 conservatives thought that he would be a better prime minister. So basically, they want the conservatives but with Callaghan as prime minister. Yeah, I think there's a degree of truth in that. So anyway, they don't get that because 1979 is a big break in British politics. Obviously, it's the inauguration of Thatcherism because she does come in.
令人惊讶的是，十分之四的保守党人认为他会是一位更好的首相。所以基本上，他们想要保守党，但由卡拉汉担任首相。是的，我认为这有一定道理。总之，他们没能如愿，因为1979年是英国政治的一个重大转折点。显然，这是撒切尔主义的开端，因为她确实上台了。
She comes in with a 43-seat majority. And then, of course, Tom, her popularity sinks to the greatest nadir, then the worst trough that any prime ministerial sort of rating had ever descended to. And everybody thinks that she'll be a one-term aberration. Right. So you said that it's a great break in British politics. I think it should be a break in this episode as well. And when we come back, let's look at the 1983 election and find out
她以43个席位的多数优势上台。然后，当然，汤姆，她的受欢迎程度跌到了最低谷，那是任何首相支持率曾经降到的最糟糕的低谷。每个人都认为她只会是昙花一现的一届政府。对。所以你说这是英国政治的一个重大转折点。我认为这也应该是本集的一个转折点。当我们回来时，让我们看看1983年的选举，看看
whether Mrs. Thatcher wins it or not. Huge tension. the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
撒切尔夫人是否赢得了选举。巨大的紧张感。越是这样，就越感觉你身处证人保护计划中。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么样的浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改拿铁订单太晚了吗？但有了KitchenAid的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些想法了，因为你本可以在家自己制作浓缩咖啡。现在就在KitchenAid.ca选购吧。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. We're a week away here in Britain from going to the polls.
我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。就是therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》（The Rest is History）。在英国，我们距离投票还有一周的时间。
And to mark that, we are looking at earlier election campaigns, what they can tell us about their effectiveness, their function, their evolution. And Dominic, we've reached the 80s, the age of Thatcherism. And you were saying before the break that during the first Thatcher government, she becomes spectacularly unpopular. It seems like the economy's in meltdown, unemployment touches 3 million. But then of course, as listeners to our episodes on the Falkland War will know, spectacular military success intervenes. But you also say if i remember your most recent book correctly that she would have won probably anyway even without the falklands would definitely have won not probably would definitely have won so that will appall some
为了纪念这一点，我们正在回顾早期的竞选活动，看看它们能告诉我们关于其有效性、功能和演变的信息。多米尼克，我们已经到了80年代，撒切尔主义的时代。你在休息前说，在第一届撒切尔政府期间，她变得极其不受欢迎。经济似乎处于崩溃状态，失业人数达到300万。但当然，正如我们关于福克兰群岛战争剧集的听众所知，壮观的军事胜利介入了。但你也说，如果我没记错你最近的书，即使没有福克兰群岛，她可能也会赢，肯定会赢，不是可能，是肯定会赢，所以这会让一些
listeners who believe that uh the falklands changed mrs thatcher's fortunes i don't think it did and actually the british journal of Political Science did a very detailed statistical analysis, which would fill most people with absolute trepidation because it's got a lot of graphs. You love a graph. And they showed, I think, pretty clearly that the polls were moving back in Mrs Thatcher's direction even before the war happened, that all the economic indicators, all the things that contribute to a shift in the momentum, say interest rates, mortgage rates, the rate of inflation, property prices, a sense of consumer confidence, but not unemployment. They were moving in her direction throughout 1982. Basically, what the Falklands War does is it accelerated a turn in Tory fortunes that
听众感到震惊，他们认为福克兰群岛改变了撒切尔夫人的命运。我不认为如此，事实上，《英国政治科学杂志》做了一个非常详细的统计分析，这会让大多数人感到绝对的恐惧，因为它有很多图表。你喜欢图表。他们非常清楚地表明，我认为，即使在战争发生之前，民调就已经开始向撒切尔夫人倾斜，所有的经济指标，所有那些促成势头转变的事情，比如利率、抵押贷款利率、通货膨胀率、房价、消费者信心感，但失业率除外。在1982年全年，它们都在向她有利的方向发展。基本上，福克兰群岛战争所做的是加速了保守党命运的转变，而这种转变
was already underway. By 1983, the effect had kind of worn off. So the Tories were where they would always have been anyway. But doesn't that, I mean, the fact that Britain is kind of starting to boom in London, in the South, but that in other areas, people are on the scrap heap and towns are going into meltdown and decaying, the sense of a kind of polarized society, does that sharpen the debates not just in 1983 but throughout the 80s yes it does so i had to restrain myself this morning from just stuffing the notes full of quotations from my book or my notes for future books i know dominic i know so there are amazing
已经在进行中了。到了1983年，这种影响已经消失了。所以保守党处于他们无论如何都会处于的位置。但难道不是吗，我的意思是，英国在伦敦、在南部开始繁荣，但在其他地区，人们处于失业边缘，城镇正在崩溃和衰败，这种两极分化的社会感，难道没有加剧不仅是1983年，而且整个80年代的辩论吗？是的，确实如此。所以我今天早上不得不克制自己，不要把笔记里塞满我书中的引语或未来书籍的笔记。我知道，多米尼克，我知道。所以有令人惊叹的
rants by people like salman rushdie or the feminist novelist Angela Carter about Britain has become fascist. She's the most evil person who's ever existed. Our editorial in The Guardian that says this is probably the last election in which we'll ever get to vote. So this is quite Churchill talking about the Gestapo. Oh, but on steroids, right? Churchill was doing a bit of pantomime. You know how it is with Churchill.
像萨尔曼·拉什迪（Salman Rushdie）或女权主义小说家安吉拉·卡特（Angela Carter）这样的人发表的咆哮，说英国已经变成了法西斯国家。她是史上最邪恶的人。《卫报》的社论说，这可能是我们最后一次投票的选举。所以这就像丘吉尔谈论盖世太保一样。哦，但那是加强版的，对吧？丘吉尔当时是在演戏。你知道丘吉尔就是那样。
Churchill would say something absolutely ridiculous and then he'd go and drink a pint of champagne afterwards or something and just forget all about it. Whereas this is what people are genuinely believing. So the Guardian said this could well be the last election because either elections will be banned under the new prison camp fascist state, or more plausibly, Mrs. Thatcher will have blown up the world with Ronald Reagan and we'll all be dead. There is a sense of the rhetoric being really, really heightened among people who are interested in politics, but then the remaining 95% of the population are just watching breakfast TV and thinking about Bananarama or Bucks Fizz or something, and are not invested in this to anything like the same degree, I would say. But in terms of the parallels that this election holds up to the one that we're currently going through, there is a parallel, isn't there? Because in 1983, the vote on the left was divided. So you
丘吉尔会说一些极其荒谬的话，然后他会去喝一品脱香槟之类的，然后就把一切都忘了。而这是人们真正相信的事情。《卫报》说这很可能是最后一次选举，因为要么在新建立的集中营法西斯国家下选举将被禁止，或者更合理的是，撒切尔夫人会和罗纳德·里根一起炸毁世界，我们都会死。对于那些对政治感兴趣的人来说，这种修辞确实被极大地夸大了，但剩下的95%的人口只是在看早餐电视，想着香蕉女郎（Bananarama）或巴克斯·菲兹（Bucks Fizz）之类的东西，我认为他们并没有投入到同样的程度。但就这次选举与我们目前正在经历的选举所持有的相似之处而言，确实存在相似之处，不是吗？因为在1983年，左翼的选票被分裂了。所以你
had a Labour Party that had swung quite sharply to the left, and that had generated a split with people leaving and forming the Social Democratic Party, the SDP, which then goes into alliance with the Liberals. And Mrs. Thatcher just hoovers up all the boats on the right and storms to victory and the same thing is happening now but reversed because you have a united labour party and you have the tories who are scrapping over votes with reform under nigel farage who is to their right yeah and basically our parliamentary system first past the post system hates and punishes divisions brutally yeah it does absolutely right so here's another thing where some listeners will now at this point turn the podcast off and never listen to it again it's commonly said mrs thatcher only wins because she never won more than 50 percent
有一个工党，它已经急剧向左转，这导致了分裂，人们离开并组建了社会民主党（SDP），该党随后与自由党结盟。而撒切尔夫人只是横扫了右翼的所有选票，并以压倒性优势获胜，现在同样的事情正在发生，但反过来了，因为你有一个团结的工党，而保守党正在与奈杰尔·法拉奇（Nigel Farage）领导的改革党争夺选票，后者在他们右侧。是的，基本上我们的议会制度，领先者当选制度，痛恨并残酷地惩罚分裂。是的，确实如此，绝对正确。所以这是另一件事，一些听众现在可能会关掉播客，再也不听了。人们常说撒切尔夫人获胜只是因为她从未获得超过50%
of the vote so it's commonly said she only wins because of the division of the opposition and if only the opposition had been able to work together then that dreadful woman would never have had the chance to destroy this country. That's what people say. I think that is wrong. In fact, I know that's wrong because studies of the election have shown, I think beyond any reasonable doubt, that if the SDP Liberal Alliance had not existed, a lot of their voters would have voted Conservative. Oh, that is interesting. And there is actually an argument that had they not existed, and by the way, it's impossible to imagine an alternative reality
的选票，所以人们常说她获胜只是因为反对派的分裂，如果反对派能够合作，那么那个可怕的女人就永远没有机会摧毁这个国家。人们就是这么说的。我认为那是错的。事实上，我知道那是错的，因为对选举的研究表明，我认为毫无疑问，如果社会民主党与自由党联盟不存在，他们的许多选民会投票给保守党。哦，那很有趣。事实上有一种观点认为，如果他们不存在，顺便说一句，无法想象一个他们不存在的替代现实
in which they don't exist. They always would have existed. I mean, don't forget the Liberals had won almost 20% of the vote in 1974. So even if there's no SDP, the Liberals are still there. But if they hadn't existed, there's an argument that Mrs Thatcher would actually have won an even bigger majority. Because at that point, a very, very bitterly divided Labour Party under Michael Foot, who's 140, he looks 300. Yeah, he does.
他们总是会存在的。我的意思是，别忘了自由党在1974年赢得了近20%的选票。所以即使没有社会民主党，自由党仍然在那里。但如果他们不存在，有一种观点认为撒切尔夫人实际上会赢得更大的多数。因为在那时，迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot）领导的工党非常、非常痛苦地分裂了，他140岁了，看起来像300岁。是的，他确实是。
In many ways, a great man. Wonderful books about Byron and Swift. Yeah. If you want an essay on Jonathan Swift, he's absolutely a man. Yeah. Not to be sniffed at, but there was a cover on Private Eye that showed a kind of very old woman huddled up beneath a blanket. I remember that. Clearly on the point of death.
在许多方面，他是一位伟人。关于拜伦和斯威夫特的精彩书籍。是的。如果你想要一篇关于乔纳森·斯威夫特（Jonathan Swift）的文章，他绝对是个人才。是的。不可小觑，但《私家侦探》（Private Eye）杂志封面上展示了一个被毯子裹住的老妇人。我记得那个。显然处于死亡边缘。
Yeah. And the nurse kind of offering a glass and saying, come on, Mr. Foot, you've got to do your election broadcast. I know. He's too old. His image was terrible. But also their campaign was so bitterly divided. Their manifesto, one of their own MPs, Gerald Kaufman, called it the longest suicide note in history
是的。护士递过一杯水说，来吧，富特先生，你得做你的竞选广播了。我知道。他太老了。他的形象太糟糕了。而且他们的竞选活动也极其分裂。他们的竞选纲领，他们自己的一位议员杰拉尔德·考夫曼（Gerald Kaufman）称之为历史上最长的自杀遗书
because it was very Jeremy Corbyn, actually. It was a massive manifesto with loads of very extravagant promises, unilateral nuclear disarmament being one of them. But the other interesting dividing line in this election, which some listeners may enjoy hearing about, is Europe. Because in that campaign, Labour's proposal was to take us out of what became the EU without a referendum. Peter Shaw, who was the keenest Eurosceptic sort of frontbencher in the Labour Party. Mr. Legxit.
因为这实际上非常像杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）。这是一个庞大的竞选纲领，带有大量非常奢侈的承诺，单方面核裁军就是其中之一。但这次选举中另一个有趣的界限，一些听众可能会喜欢听，那就是欧洲。因为在那次竞选活动中，工党的提议是在没有全民公投的情况下带我们退出后来成为欧盟的组织。彼得·肖（Peter Shore），工党中最热衷于疑欧的前座议员。脱欧先生（Mr. Legxit）。
Mr. Legxit. He said that entering Europe had been a rape of the British people and their constitution. And it would be a disgrace to have a referendum because referendums were un-British that we should just leave. And actually, here's the really interesting thing. Mrs. Thatcher, 1983. 1983 is a landmark in the history of elections. I'm just looking at this speech. It's our biggest trading area and there are jobs in exports and then so
脱欧先生。他说加入欧洲是对英国人民及其宪法的强奸。举行全民公投将是一种耻辱，因为全民公投是不英国的，我们应该直接离开。事实上，这里有非常有趣的事情。撒切尔夫人，1983年。1983年是选举史上的一个里程碑。我正在看这个演讲。这是我们最大的贸易区，出口中有就业机会，然后
many companies choose to invest in britain because they know there's a free market entrance to the whole of europe yeah well there you go so what's interesting about that she launches her campaign on the radio on radio to the jimmy young show very populist program so for our overseas listeners it's like a fun talk show chat very, very accessible to the broadest possible audience. And that's typical Thatcher. And that's something that people had not really done before. She goes for sort of down market or mid market media options. And unlike, let's say, Harold Wilson, she is not doing rallies with lots of opponents in town halls and things like that. It's a television campaign.
许多公司选择投资英国，因为他们知道有一个通往整个欧洲的自由市场入口。是的，好吧，就是这样。所以有趣的是，她在广播中发起了她的竞选活动，在吉米·杨（Jimmy Young）节目中，这是一个非常民粹主义的节目。所以对于我们的海外听众来说，这就像一个有趣的脱口秀聊天，非常、非常容易被最广泛的受众接受。这就是典型的撒切尔。这是人们以前没有真正做过的事情。她选择了低端或中端媒体选项。而且与哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）不同，她没有在市政厅等地与大量反对者举行集会。这是一场电视竞选。
It's the first real television campaign. If you want a really good example of this, Tom, somebody that you will know, Robert Harris, novelist, all his books and sister and stuff, he was then a political correspondent, and you can see it on YouTube, a very famous clip. He follows her around a factory, and he's saying,
这是第一次真正的电视竞选。如果你想要一个非常好的例子，汤姆，一个你会认识的人，罗伯特·哈里斯（Robert Harris），小说家，他所有的书等等，他当时是一名政治记者，你可以在YouTube上看到它，一个非常著名的片段。他跟着她绕着一家工厂走，他说，
everything is manicured for the television cameras everything is planned this is british politics in 1983 he's doing all this very american style and he doesn't realize what he's talking to the camera that she's stopped what she's doing and she's come up behind him and she's standing staring at him quizzically while he's doing the piece to camera it's a really really funny clip yeah it is funny but there is a rally that the Tories hold, isn't there? Where Kenny Everett, the zany disc jockey, who had had an affair with Tommy Nutter. Wow.
一切都为电视摄像机精心修饰，一切都经过计划，这就是1983年的英国政治。他正在以非常美国化的风格做这一切，他没有意识到他在对着摄像机说话时，她已经停下了她正在做的事情，她走到他身后，在他对着摄像机做报道时，她站在那里困惑地盯着他。这真是一个非常、非常有趣的片段。是的，这很有趣，但保守党确实举行了一场集会，不是吗？肯尼·埃弗里特（Kenny Everett），那个古怪的唱片骑师，他曾与汤米·纳特（Tommy Nutter）有过一段恋情。哇。
Savile Row Taylor. Of suit fame. Of suit fame. It's great when we link up all the different strands of... I know, it all connects. And he's wearing a pair of outsized foam hands. Yeah. And he cries out, let's bomb Russia.
萨维尔街的裁缝。西装名声。西装名声。当我们把所有不同的线索联系起来时，这很棒……我知道，这一切都联系在一起。他戴着一副超大的泡沫手套。是的。他大喊，让我们轰炸俄罗斯。
It's actually, let's bomb Russia. it's actually let's bomb russia let's kick michael foot stick away yes yeah so that that has no impact yeah it was a slight embarrassment for mrs thatcher but not a massive one i mean the interesting thing there right is that the tories in 1983 they had the zany djs that was a rally. And the Tories back then had a genuinely very strong, vibrant sort of youth support. I mean, all these people who thought Toryism equals ambition, aspiration, a better life. It's the future, modernity. I mean, nobody obviously said that for about the last 20 years. I mean, maybe they did when Cameron came in, but certainly they're not saying it now. And I think that's an aspect of Thatcher's appeal. She's not
实际上是，让我们轰炸俄罗斯。实际上是让我们轰炸俄罗斯，让我们踢迈克尔·富特，把棍子拿走。是的，是的，所以那没有影响。是的，这对撒切尔夫人来说是一个轻微的尴尬，但不是一个巨大的尴尬。我的意思是，有趣的是，保守党在1983年，他们有古怪的DJ，那是一场集会。而当时的保守党确实有非常强大、充满活力的青年支持。我的意思是，所有这些认为保守主义等于雄心、抱负、更美好生活的人。这是未来，现代性。我的意思是，显然过去20年里没有人这么说过。我的意思是，也许卡梅伦上台时他们说过，但他们现在肯定没这么说。我认为这是撒切尔吸引力的一方面。她实际上不是
actually a reactionary politician. She's a forward-looking one. And it's her campaigns in the 80s that are much more modern, forward-looking, glitzier, slicker, all of these kinds of things, which actually now we don't really associate with the Tories. Although, I mean, the most memorable speech from that campaign was a warning not to be young or indeed to be old. And that came from Neil Kinnock, who essentially, I mean, it's so powerful, this speech. So Neil Kinnock is Welsh and in Britain, great powers of oratory are kind of very much associated with the Welsh, although it can kind of veer into windbaggery. So he would be known as the Welsh windbag. Not something that would
一个反动派政治家。她是一个展望未来的人。她在80年代的竞选活动更加现代、前瞻、更华丽、更圆滑，所有这些东西，实际上现在我们并没有真正把它们与保守党联系起来。虽然，我的意思是，那次竞选中最令人难忘的演讲是对不要年轻或不要年老的警告。那来自尼尔·基诺克（Neil Kinnock），他本质上，我的意思是，这太有力了，这个演讲。所以尼尔·基诺克是威尔士人，在英国，伟大的演说能力在某种程度上与威尔士人非常相关，尽管它可能会转向夸夸其谈。所以他被称为威尔士夸夸其谈者。这不是那种会
ever happen on this podcast, Tom, windbaggery. So he would be known as the Welsh windbag. Not something that would ever happen on this podcast, Tom. Windbaggery. No, of course not. That would never happen. But Kinnock, on the back of this, becomes leader of the Labour Party and fights two campaigns, both of which he loses. But when he catches fire, I mean, his speeches are probably the only ones that have any cut through, really, as in the kind of Gladstonian sense of great soaring oratory. And the measure ones that have any cut through really, as in the kind of Gladstonian sense of great soaring oratory. And the measure of that is in the 1987 one, he does a part of a broadcast in which he talks about how he was the first Kinnock, you know, to go to university and all this kind of stuff. And it's so powerful that it encourages Biden basically to copy it. And that then
在这个播客上发生的事情，汤姆，夸夸其谈。所以他被称为威尔士夸夸其谈者。这不是那种会发生在这个播客上的事情，汤姆。夸夸其谈。不，当然不会。那永远不会发生。但基诺克，在此基础上，成为了工党领袖并进行了两次竞选，两次都输了。但当他火起来时，我的意思是，他的演讲可能是唯一真正有穿透力的，就像格莱斯顿（Gladstonian）意义上的伟大高昂演说。而衡量
terminates Biden's presidential ambitions for decades and decades, meaning that Biden can only become president when he's 210. Yeah, and everyone's forgotten. Everyone is dead who remembers it. Yeah, so Kinnock's oratory perhaps has affected the course of the American election this year. Why am I the first Kinnock in a thousand generations to go to university? Was it because they were not clever, these people who could work with their hands and make beautiful? You know, he goes on like this. It's brilliant.
那一点是在1987年的那次，他做了一部分广播，他在其中谈到了他是第一个基诺克，你知道，去上大学等等。这太有力了，以至于它基本上鼓励了拜登去抄袭它。而那随后终止了拜登几十年的总统野心，意味着拜登只能在210岁时成为总统。是的，每个人都忘了。记得它的人都死了。是的，所以基诺克的演说可能影响了今年美国选举的进程。为什么我是千百代以来第一个去上大学的基诺克？是因为他们不聪明吗，这些可以用双手工作并制造美丽的人？你知道，他继续这样说。这太棒了。
Yeah, it's brilliant. Biden did it. It wasn't so good, it's brilliant. Biden did it. It wasn't so good because he's talking about Pennsylvania, not Wales. So it doesn't have the same emotional... Scranton. Yeah, Scranton, exactly. It's not the same as like the Welsh Valleys. But the election in 1992, Mrs. Thatcher has gone.
是的，这太棒了。拜登做了。它不是那么好，这太棒了。拜登做了。它不是那么好，因为他在谈论宾夕法尼亚州，而不是威尔士。所以它没有同样的情感……斯克兰顿（Scranton）。是的，斯克兰顿，没错。它不像威尔士山谷那样。但1992年的选举，撒切尔夫人已经走了。
John Major has succeeded as Tory leader and is widely expected to lose. And Kinnock is still Labour leader and they hold a massive rally in Sheffield. And he gets so carried away and he starts shouting, all right, all right. And supposedly this loses him the election. I never understand it. I mean, I've kind of watched it and I thought it was all right. I remember it being on the news. You loved it, Tom. You loved it. Tom had tears in his eyes watching that rally. I didn't think, oh, that's terrible. He's going to lose the election. Do you know what? I saw that on the news, probably watching the same news bulletin you did. It was John Cole bbc political correspondent with a
约翰·梅杰（John Major）接任保守党领袖，普遍预计会输。而基诺克仍然是工党领袖，他们在谢菲尔德举行了一场大规模集会。他太得意忘形了，开始大喊，好吧，好吧。据推测，这让他输掉了选举。我从来不明白这一点。我的意思是，我看了它，我觉得还可以。我记得它在新闻上。你喜欢它，汤姆。你喜欢它。汤姆看着那场集会时眼里含着泪水。我没有想，哦，那太糟糕了。他要输掉选举了。你知道吗？我在新闻上看到了，可能和你看了同一个新闻简报。那是约翰·科尔（John Cole），BBC政治记者，带着一个
spended northern irish voice and he said it was the most amazing rally he'd seen in all his years covering british politics it's held in sheffield the labour people came on stage and they were introduced your next home secretary gerald corfman pick it up whoa and everyone kind of literally baying and sobbing it was basically a throwback to the 18th century mobs. You know, people so excited. And Kenneth comes out and he does that thing. Later, when he lost unexpectedly, people said, oh, this tremendous hubris was what had undermined him. The American convention style campaign.
浓重的北爱尔兰口音，他说这是他多年报道英国政治以来见过的最令人惊叹的集会。它在谢菲尔德举行，工党的人走上舞台，他们被介绍，你的下一任内政大臣杰拉尔德·考夫曼（Gerald Kaufman），接住它，哇，每个人都简直在咆哮和啜泣，这基本上是18世纪暴民的回归。你知道，人们太兴奋了。基诺克出来做了那个动作。后来，当他意外失败时，人们说，哦，这种巨大的傲慢是削弱他的原因。美国会议风格的竞选。
I don't think that's true at all. I do, however, think that 92 is a challenge to my hypothesis that elections don't matter, because I think this does matter. I think when elections matter, when campaigns matter, it's because they accentuate, they amplify anxieties that were latent, that already existed. So in this election, the anxiety is about basically Labour will tax you. And the Tories advertising hammered on that relentlessly. Labour's tax bombshell. Now, the other thing about 92 that I think I'd love to see return is John Major, who everybody had written off as basically Mr. Pooter, basically banal, suburban. He,
我不认为那是真的。然而，我确实认为92年是对我关于选举无关紧要的假设的挑战，因为我认为这确实很重要。我认为当选举很重要，当竞选活动很重要时，是因为它们突出了，放大了潜在的、已经存在的焦虑。所以在这场选举中，焦虑基本上是关于工党会向你征税。而保守党的广告无情地抨击了这一点。工党的税收重磅炸弹。现在，关于92年的另一件事，我认为我很乐意看到它回归，那就是约翰·梅杰，每个人都把他写成基本上是普特先生（Mr. Pooter），基本上平庸、郊区化。他，
in this election, won what at the time, and I think possibly remains to this day, or at least remained for a long time, the largest number of votes ever won by a political party. And it was partly because he did a retro campaign, Tom. He did. He got on a soapbox. And you were saying how politicians today haven't been seasoned in the school of hard knocks. They haven't been out on the streets. But Major had. Major was a councillor here in Brixton, where I'm sitting right now, and not a naturally Tory-friendly place, it has to be said.
在这次选举中，赢得了当时，而且我认为可能至今仍然，或者至少长期保持的，政党赢得的最大票数。这部分是因为他进行了一场复古竞选，汤姆。他确实做了。他站上了肥皂箱。你说今天的政治家没有在艰难困苦的学校里磨练过。他们没有走上街头。但梅杰有。梅杰是布里克斯顿（Brixton）的一名议员，我现在正坐在那里，不得不说，这不是一个天生对保守党友好的地方。
But he'd come through that, and he'd risen to become leader of the Tories and he thought well I'll go on the stump didn't he got out his soapbox and he took it round and he had a loud speaker and people would gather and boo him and things yeah the soapbox is a wooden crate so basically you put this crate down and town centre get up on the crate crate, get his loudspeaker or loud hailer, and he'd say, you should vote conservative because of... In this sort of tinny, loud hailer voice. And some people would say, rubbish, what about unemployment? You know, whatever. It was a great scene. It was a throwback to an earlier age of politics.
但他经历了这一切，他升任保守党领袖，他想，好吧，我会去竞选，不是吗？他拿出了他的肥皂箱，他带着它到处走，他有一个扩音器，人们会聚集起来嘘他之类的。是的，肥皂箱是一个木箱，所以基本上你把这个箱子放在市中心，站上箱子，拿上他的扩音器或扩音喇叭，他会说，你应该投票给保守党，因为……用这种刺耳的扩音喇叭声音。有些人会说，胡说八道，失业怎么办？你知道，无论什么。这是一个伟大的场景。这是对早期政治时代的回归。
But it worked for him because he did have an unusual background for a Tory leader. The circus. Yeah, he's famously the only man to have run away from the circus to join an accountancy firm. But he actually, they did a party political broadcast in that campaign where he went back to Brixton and he kind of revisited all his old haunts. It's actually really well done because he's in the car. The car is going towards his old house. He's saying, is it there? Is it there? It's still, look, it's still there. He's talking about his old house. And this sort of thing that he is he is so ordinary and the ordinariness is the point you say that i mean i agree the ordinary was the point and was was his kind of usp really but the weird thing is
但这对他有效，因为他确实有一个对保守党领袖来说不寻常的背景。马戏团。是的，他著名地是唯一一个从马戏团逃出来加入会计师事务所的人。但他实际上，他们在竞选活动中做了一个政党政治广播，他回到了布里克斯顿，他重游了他所有的旧地。这实际上做得非常好，因为他在车里。车正开往他的老房子。他说，它在那里吗？它在那里吗？它仍然，看，它仍然在那里。他在谈论他的老房子。这种他如此普通的事情，而普通性就是重点。你说那个，我的意思是，我同意普通性就是重点，而且确实是他的某种独特卖点，但奇怪的是
on television he did come across very boring and he's always portrayed as very gray and eating peas and you know tucking his shirt into his pants yeah. But I've met him a couple of times in person. He's a very charismatic man. I mean, he's very kind of tall, good looking, amusing, funny. And I just wonder whether going out into the streets enabled that aspect of him. There was something about television that kind of bleached him of what made him an impressive figure in person. I agree with that. And Tom, I don't think we should turn this into the John Major fan cast, but all of that said,
在电视上，他确实显得非常无聊，他总是被描绘成非常灰暗，吃豌豆，你知道，把衬衫塞进裤子里。是的。但我亲自见过他几次。他是一个非常有魅力的人。我的意思是，他非常高，好看，有趣，好笑。我只是想知道走上街头是否启用了他的那一面。电视上有一些东西，把它漂白了，使他在个人面前成为一个令人印象深刻的人物。我同意这一点。汤姆，我不认为我们应该把这变成约翰·梅杰粉丝播客，但话虽如此，
I once went to an event at the National Archives in my capacities on the board of their trust, whatever, and John Major came to give a speech about archives. And I thought, this is going to be the worst thing ever. A speech about archives, which is intrinsically quite boring, and I say that as a historian, and B, it's by John Major.
我曾经以董事会成员的身份参加了国家档案馆的一次活动，约翰·梅杰来发表关于档案馆的演讲。我想，这将是有史以来最糟糕的事情。关于档案馆的演讲，这本质上很无聊，我作为历史学家这么说，而且B，它是约翰·梅杰讲的。
And he stood up and he gave his speech and I thought, Jesus Christ, he's good. That was one of the best speeches I've ever heard. And then he went around shaking people's hands and introducing. He's very tall, isn't he? He's like formidably physical. I say it's charismatic is the word. I know it sounds absolutely bonkers to say that of John Major. I thought, I mean, that election, both leaders were very charismatic. And if you think about the people we've had in more recent elections, that sense of charisma and moral power combined, both of them had it in their different ways. Kinnock. So I've interviewed Kinnock and spent time with him.
他站起来发表了演讲，我想，天哪，他真棒。那是我听过的最好的演讲之一。然后他走来走去与人们握手并介绍。他很高，不是吗？他看起来身体非常强壮。我说魅力是这个词。我知道说约翰·梅杰有魅力听起来绝对疯狂。我想，我的意思是，那次选举，两位领导人都非常有魅力。如果你想想我们在最近的选举中拥有的人，那种魅力和道德力量的结合，他们两人以不同的方式都拥有它。基诺克。所以我采访过基诺克，并和他在一起待过。
He's an incredibly charismatic man. He's a great fun to be around. A joker, good humoured, again, a real presence to him. Goodness, could he articulate his ideals in a way that kind of made the hair on the back of your neck rise? Yeah, absolutely agreed. I remember that election campaign. It was the first time I was in London. I found it exciting. And, you know, you didn't quite know who was going to win.
他是一个非常有魅力的人。和他在一起很有趣。一个开玩笑的人，幽默感好，再次，他有一种真正的存在感。天哪，他能以一种让你后颈汗毛竖起的方式表达他的理想吗？是的，绝对同意。我记得那次竞选活动。那是我第一次在伦敦。我觉得它很令人兴奋。而且，你知道，你不太知道谁会赢。
And I thought both the leaders were very impressive, as actually the Labour leader who campaigns in the next election in 1997. Also, I thought... Well, Tom, let me read you this and you tell me which election you think this is from. It's from American coverage. From Oxford's genteel debating scientists to tattooed punk rockers, Britain's youth seems to speak with the same voice about the May the 1st election. And that voice seems to be saying, who cares? I don't think whatever happens is going to make any difference. It's 1945 again, Tom. I don't think whatever happens is going to make any difference. See, it's 1945 again, Tom. I don't think whatever happens is going to make any difference,
我觉得两位领导人都非常令人印象深刻，实际上在1997年下一次选举中竞选的工党领袖也是如此。我也觉得……好吧，汤姆，让我读给你听，你告诉我你认为这是哪次选举。它来自美国报道。从牛津文雅的辩论科学家到纹身的朋克摇滚乐手，英国的青年似乎用同样的声音谈论5月1日的选举。而那个声音似乎在说，谁在乎呢？我不认为无论发生什么会有任何区别。这是1945年再次，汤姆。我不认为无论发生什么会有任何区别。看，这是1945年再次，汤姆。我不认为无论发生什么会有任何区别，
said a young woman in a jean jacket, a pair of fashionable sunglasses perched on her head. But will she vote? Never have done, never will do, she chirped. And her friend added simultaneously, no, sorry, I would vote if I knew more about it, said a dark-haired woman in carefully applied makeup. I would, but I don't, so I'm not going to vote.
一个穿着牛仔夹克、头上戴着一副时尚太阳镜的年轻女子说。但她会投票吗？从来没投过，永远不会投，她叽叽喳喳地说。她的朋友同时补充说，不，抱歉，如果我知道更多关于它的信息，我会投票，一个化着精心妆容的黑发女子说。我会的，但我不知道，所以我不会去投票。
Now, which election is that? That's the 97, I guess. 97. So the supposed, everybody's very enthusiastic. Things can only get better. Blair landslide, cool Britannia. And yet the interesting thing about that, Tony Blair did not enthuse people, as everybody says. Now, if you listen to Alistair Campbell on The Rest Is Politics, I'm sure he'll tell you something different. Don't it? You're wrong. He absolutely enthused me. But here's the thing. Turnout was fully 6% lower in 1997 than 1992.
现在，那是哪次选举？那是97年，我猜。97年。所以所谓的，每个人都非常热情。事情只会变得更好。布莱尔压倒性胜利，酷不列颠（Cool Britannia）。然而关于那一点有趣的是，托尼·布莱尔并没有像每个人说的那样激励人们。现在，如果你在《剩下的就是政治》（The Rest Is Politics）上听阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔（Alistair Campbell），我相信他会告诉你一些不同的东西。不是吗？你错了。他绝对激励了我。但这里有一件事。1997年的投票率比1992年整整低了6%。
But that's because everyone knew Labour were going to win. People turn out when it's unclear who's going to win, surely. The Blair effect is not to fire people up with political enthusiasm. It's just to turn them off politics. Because, Dominic, totally wrong. Let me continue. I've got the facts and you don't. I've got anecdotal evidence, Dominic.
但那是因为每个人都知道工党会赢。人们在不清楚谁会赢时才会出来投票，肯定。布莱尔效应不是用政治热情点燃人们。它只是让他们对政治感到厌烦。因为，多米尼克，完全错了。让我继续。我有事实，而你没有。我有轶事证据，多米尼克。
Rubbish. In 2001, turnout fell even lower under Blair to 59%, its lowest level since 1918. So actually, Blair works as the ultimate political turnoff. The more people see of him, the less likely they are to vote on either side. But the reason for that, surely, is that people just assume he's going to win. Well, we'll see this time, won't we? Whether that is the same. I mean, everybody thought Boris was going to win in 2019, didn't they? I mean, ultimately, you can't deny that. Everyone thought Boris Johnson was going to win. And turnout then was almost 10% higher in 2019 than it was in 1997. But 2019, there was lots at stake. And it wasn't in 97.
胡说八道。2001年，在布莱尔领导下，投票率进一步下降至59%，是自1918年以来的最低水平。所以实际上，布莱尔是终极的政治厌恶者。人们看到他的次数越多，他们投票给任何一方的可能性就越小。但其原因肯定是因为人们只是假设他会赢。好吧，这次我们会看到的，不是吗？是否是一样的。我的意思是，每个人都认为鲍里斯（Boris）会在2019年赢，不是吗？我的意思是，最终，你不能否认这一点。每个人都认为鲍里斯·约翰逊会赢。而2019年的投票率比1997年高出近10%。但2019年，有很多利害关系。而97年没有。
People just thought, oh, you know, we're fed up. Tory's been around forever. Things are going to get better. I know Goldhanger podcast is like a Tony Blair fan zone and they don't want to hear it. Listen, Dominic, you have your stats and your figures, but I have my anecdotal evidence, my memories. So what's your favourite?
人们只是想，哦，你知道，我们受够了。保守党一直在那里。事情会变得更好。我知道Goldhanger播客就像托尼·布莱尔粉丝区，他们不想听到这个。听着，多米尼克，你有你的统计数据和数字，但我有我的轶事证据，我的记忆。那么你最喜欢的是什么？
There's been four elections since 2010. So it's 2010, Cameron and Clegg hung Parliament 2015, Miliband I did quite enjoy that Labour were terrible in that election And it was full of comic moments My favourite bit was when Ed Miliband went to see Russell Brand Oh yeah
自2010年以来已经有四次选举。所以是2010年，卡梅伦和克莱格（Clegg）悬浮议会，2015年，米利班德（Miliband），我确实很享受工党在那次选举中表现糟糕，而且它充满了喜剧时刻。我最喜欢的部分是埃德·米利班德（Ed Miliband）去见拉塞尔·布兰德（Russell Brand）。哦，是的。
The comedian and person who's been accused of all kinds of bad behaviour Controversial star And your old student Owen Jones Yeah Wrote an article about it saying russell brand has come out for labor and the tories should be worried yeah i remember that i still think that's the funniest headline about a general election campaign that i can think of and it's obviously in light of recent events it's become even funnier as the tour is eas ease to that overall majority. So then there's 2017. Now, 2017 is another one that basically punctures my thesis because 2017, the campaign did matter. Because if the election had been held and there'd been no campaign,
那个喜剧演员和被指控有各种不良行为的人。有争议的明星。还有你的老学生欧文·琼斯（Owen Jones）。是的。写了一篇关于它的文章，说拉塞尔·布兰德已经支持工党，保守党应该担心。是的，我记得那个。我仍然认为那是我能想到的关于大选竞选的最有趣的标题，而且显然鉴于最近发生的事件，它变得更加有趣了，因为保守党轻松获得了多数席位。所以接下来是2017年。现在，2017年是另一个基本上戳破了我的论点的选举，因为2017年，竞选活动确实很重要。因为如果选举举行了，而没有竞选活动，
I think Theresa May would have won a handsome, handsome majority. But unfortunately, she insisted on campaigning and she was just such a stilted and just not a natural campaigner. I mean, weirdly, for someone who got to the top of politics, she's not a huckster, not a salesman. And of course, Jeremy Corbyn was not really saying anything very substantive, I wouldn't say. I mean, I think they were both absolutely terrible. And if you compare Major and Kinnett or Callaghan and Thatcher, you just kind of weep, really. Yeah.
我认为特蕾莎·梅（Theresa May）会赢得一个漂亮的、漂亮的多数。但不幸的是，她坚持竞选，而她只是一个如此生硬的、不是天生的竞选者。我的意思是，奇怪的是，对于一个达到政治顶峰的人来说，她不是一个推销员，不是一个销售员。当然，杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）并没有真正说出任何非常实质性的东西，我不会这么说。我的意思是，我认为他们两个都绝对糟糕。如果你比较梅杰和基诺克，或者卡拉汉和撒切尔，你真的会哭。是的。
And I know that there's always the risk. It's a bit like music or sport, that people who kind of live in your memory when you first get into something or you first become aware of something always seem more vivid. So there's always the risk, you know, I'm now in my 50s, that the political leaders of my youth seem more impressive. I don't think it is, though. I genuinely think that the leaders in the 80s and 90s were qualitatively better, both as campaigners and as leaders, than they have been recently. Let's end by just discussing this point. Has the standard declined in this period we've been talking about? We started in 1945, Churchill and Attlee. When Churchill entered the House of Commons in the 1900s, he said of that House of Commons, there were still big personalities in it, though of course it had declined since my father's day. And you look at that House of Commons, right, which has Churchill, it will go on to have like Keir Hardie, Attlee, all these great figures in the Labour Party. If I ask with Lloyd George, Richard Haldane, Joseph Chamberlain, you're like, what? I know. And I'm aware that people are always thinking
我知道总是有风险。这有点像音乐或体育，当你第一次接触某事或第一次意识到某事时，那些活在你记忆中的人总是显得更生动。所以总是有风险，你知道，我现在50多岁了，我年轻时的政治领导人显得更令人印象深刻。我不认为如此，虽然。我真诚地认为，80年代和90年代的领导人在竞选者和领导者方面，在质量上都比最近的要好。让我们以讨论这一点结束。在这个我们一直在谈论的时期，标准下降了吗？我们从1945年开始，丘吉尔和艾德礼（Attlee）。当丘吉尔在1900年代进入下议院时，他谈到那个下议院，里面仍然有大人物，尽管当然它自父亲时代以来已经衰落了。你看看那个下议院，对吧，里面有丘吉尔，它后来会有像凯尔·哈迪（Keir Hardie）、艾德礼这样的人，工党中所有这些伟大的人物。如果我问劳合·乔治（Lloyd George）、理查德·霍尔丹（Richard Haldane）、约瑟夫·张伯伦（Joseph Chamberlain），你会说，什么？我知道。而且我知道人们总是认为
that politics is in decline, but I've reached that stage where I genuinely think it is. So I can't help it. I'm middle-aged. Who cares? But just because people always say it doesn't mean it can't be true. And I think there is no doubt that the standard of the personnel and of the campaigns, and in other words, generally the context, the ecosystem, has changed and not for the better. And why do you think that is? So I think there's a couple of reasons. To be brutal, politicians pay much less than they were relative to other professions.
政治正在衰落，但我已经到了那个阶段，我真诚地认为它确实如此。所以我无能为力。我是中年人。谁在乎呢？但仅仅因为人们总是这么说并不意味着它不是真的。而且我认为毫无疑问，人员和竞选活动的标准，换句话说，总体背景、生态系统已经改变，而且不是变得更好。你认为这是为什么？所以我认为有几个原因。说得残酷一点，政治家支付的薪水相对于其他职业要少得多。
So in other words, if you're a very ambitious, talented person, you may be inhibited from going into politics. The demands are much greater. It's a very peculiar lifestyle. I think a lot of it is actually, we talked about how there'd been a transition from the mass rallies to the televised campaigns and stuff. And I think the ecosystem, the context, the environment makes it almost impossible for politicians to shine because they are interviewed on the BBC's, frankly, terrible political shows
所以换句话说，如果你是一个非常有野心、有才华的人，你可能会被抑制进入政治。需求要大得多。这是一种非常奇特的生活方式。我认为很大程度上实际上是，我们谈到了从群众集会到电视竞选等的转变。而且我认为生态系统、背景、环境使得政治家几乎不可能闪耀，因为他们是在BBC的，坦率地说，糟糕的政治节目上被采访
for what, three minutes? They're given three answers. And if they say the slightest slip, people seize on it. I mean, here's a really good example. Churchill would be interviewed, or Wilson or whoever, and they would give a long answer that would go on for five minutes and they'd say all kinds of different things. No one would really notice. Rishi Sunak appears on the radio. He makes a joke about how he's been eating Haribos and Twixes, like sweets, to keep himself going in the campaign. It's just an offhand joke. And immediately someone rings up the station to complain and says, how cruel and insensitive at a time when we're battling with obesity. It says so much about the prime minister that he would make an offhand remark about eating
多久？三分钟？他们被给予三个答案。如果他们说了一点点失误，人们就会抓住它。我的意思是，这里有一个非常好的例子。丘吉尔会被采访，或者威尔逊或任何人，他们会给出一个持续五分钟的长答案，他们会说各种各样不同的事情。没有人会真正注意到。里希·苏纳克（Rishi Sunak）出现在广播中。他开了一个关于他一直在吃哈瑞宝（Haribos）和特威克斯（Twixes），像糖果一样，来维持他在竞选活动中的精力的玩笑。这只是一个随意的玩笑。立刻有人打电话给电台投诉，说在我们要与肥胖作斗争的时候，这太残忍和麻木不仁了。这说明了首相关于吃东西的随意评论的很多事情。
sweets in this way. But doesn't that just reflect the fact that social media now means that people can be incredibly humorless in a loud way about everything that a politician says? It does, of course, but it basically means politicians, their room to breathe has been so restricted. So there was an age when maybe Sunak Starmer, when they could actually have grown as politicians and as people, we could have seen a reflective side. They must have reflective sides. I mean, I don't believe they're stupid people. Well, I actually think that both of them, relative to the leaders that we had in more recent times, are much more impressive. I could imagine
以这种方式对待甜点。但这难道不反映了一个事实吗？即社交媒体现在意味着人们可以对政客所说的每一句话都表现得极其缺乏幽默感且大声喧哗？当然是这样，但这基本上意味着政客们的喘息空间受到了极大的限制。所以曾经有一个时代，也许苏纳克和斯塔默，他们本可以作为政客和个人真正成长，我们本可以看到他们反思的一面。他们一定有反思的一面。我的意思是，我不相信他们是愚蠢的人。嗯，我实际上认为他们两人相对于我们最近时期的领导人来说，要令人印象深刻得多。我可以想象
them appearing in a 1979 political broadcast. Well, here's the thing. If you had to put your family finances in the hands of Jeremy Corbyn, Boris Johnson, Keir Starmer, Rishi Sunak, all this trust, I mean, there's two people there who are in a different league from all the others, right? Yeah, I think so. So I think that's quite a positive notion which to end. That's quintessential centrist daddery, isn't it? No, I don't think so. I don't think so. I think it is. No.
他们出现在1979年的政治广播中。嗯，问题就在这里。如果你必须把家庭财务交给杰里米·科尔宾、鲍里斯·约翰逊、基尔·斯塔默、里希·苏纳克来打理，所有这些信任，我的意思是，那里有两个人和其他人完全不在一个档次，对吧？是的，我想是这样。所以我认为这是一个非常积极的结束语。这简直是典型的中间派老爹做派，不是吗？不，我不这么认为。我不这么认为。我认为是。不。
I think there'll be some people listening to this and saying, well, absolute melts. Corbyn is the man. Or there'll be people who say, slagging off Boris again, that's such restless politics behaviour. No, because I think that Mrs Thatcher
我想会有一些听众听到这里会说，真是彻头彻尾的软蛋。科尔宾才是真男人。或者会有一些人说，又在抨击鲍里斯了，这真是典型的《剩余即政治》的行为。不，因为我认为撒切尔夫人
was a very, very impressive campaigner. I think Attlee was. Oh, Attlee's brilliant. Yeah. You know, there are people who have led radical, transformative governments. Yeah. Who are clearly very impressive campaigner. I think Atlee was. Oh, Atlee's brilliant. Yeah. You know, there are people who have led radical, transformative governments. Yeah.
是一位非常、非常令人印象深刻的竞选者。我认为艾德礼也是。哦，艾德礼太棒了。是的。你知道，有些人领导过激进的、变革性的政府。是的。他们显然是非常令人印象深刻的竞选者。我认为艾德礼也是。哦，艾德礼太棒了。是的。你知道，有些人领导过激进的、变革性的政府。是的。
Who are clearly very impressive in all kinds of ways. I know who you're ultimately talking about, Tom. You're talking about H.H. Asquith, aren't you? So he will be joining us for the First World War. Over the next few weeks. So we are about to embark on an epic account of the build-up to the First World War. So next week, we start a four-part series on the murder of the Archduke Franz Ferdinand in Sarajevo, four episodes on that.
他们在各方面显然都非常令人印象深刻。我知道你最终在谈论谁，汤姆。你在谈论H.H.阿斯奎斯，对吧？所以他将在接下来的几周里加入我们，一起探讨第一次世界大战。所以我们即将开始一段关于第一次世界大战前夕的史诗般的叙述。所以下周，我们将开始一个关于萨拉热窝弗朗茨·斐迪南大公遇刺案的四部分系列节目，共四集。
And then we have a kind of sister series, six parts, looking at the road from Sarajevo to Britain's entry into the war on the 4th of August. And I hope you enjoy that. Well, Tom, they can't not enjoy it because it involves the best impressions you've ever done. I think you doing the Kaiser will live in my memory till my dying day. And people say that, you know, you do impersonations and the impersonations takes you over. One of the really startling things I think about the series on the build up to the war is the fact that over the course of it, I discover that I am actually the Kaiser. Yeah. The similarities are uncanny.
然后我们有一个姊妹系列，共六部分，探讨从萨拉热窝到8月4日英国参战的历程。我希望你们喜欢。嗯，汤姆，他们不可能不喜欢，因为它包含了你做过的最好的模仿。我想你模仿德皇的样子将永远留在我的记忆中，直到我死的那一天。人们常说，你知道，你做模仿，模仿会让你沉浸其中。我认为关于战争前夕系列节目最令人吃惊的事情之一是，在整个过程中，我发现我实际上就是德皇。是的。相似之处简直不可思议。
Uncanny. Came as a surprise, but the more I contemplated it, the more I came to accept its force. I think we discovered, didn't we, that basically we've often talked about what the dynamic is at the heart of this podcast, and it actually is the relationship between Franz Ferdinand and the Kaiser. Yeah. We love a hunting lodge. Let's be frank. So lots to look forward to, I hope.
不可思议。这让我感到惊讶，但我思考得越多，就越接受这种力量。我想我们发现了，不是吗？我们经常谈论这个播客的核心动力是什么，实际上就是弗朗茨·斐迪南和德皇之间的关系。是的。坦白说，我们喜欢狩猎小屋。所以，希望大家多多期待。
And for our British listeners, enjoy the last week of the election campaign. If you can. If you can. And we hope you enjoy the brutal murder in Sarajevo of the Archduke Franz Ferdinand. So until then, bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde.
对于我们的英国听众，享受竞选活动的最后一周吧。如果可以的话。如果可以的话。我们希望你们喜欢萨拉热窝弗朗茨·斐迪南大公的惨死。那么在那之前，再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩余即娱乐》。这是你们每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点演艺圈八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，
head to therestisentertainment.com That's There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。